first for the topping heat olive oil in  a frying pan  have 10 cannellini beans along with the  juices  once heated gently mash the beans with a  fork  then add sliced black olives roughly  chopped parsley  and a splash of sherry vinegar  season and leave on a gentle heat  next half a festive batter and splash  with extra virgin olive oil  he's a griddle pan until smokin and  toast the bread all side down pressing  it into the pan to chart evenly to serve  top the toasted ciabatta with a khalili  bean mixture and finish with chopped  anchovies  packed with bold flavors so easy you can  always make it blindfolded ready in  under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds